les organisateurs ont estimé à plus de 1
million le nombre de participants à la
manifestation de dimanche à paris contre
le mariage homosexuel alors que la
police de son côté a chiffré à plus tôt
cent cinquante mille le nombre de
participants parmi heures en tout cas
clémence et étienne ce sont deux jeunes
yvelinois pourquoi sont ils opposés à
cette loi le reportage de sophie vallet
d'anthony rennes ce dimanche dans le
cortège de la manifestation contre le
mariage pour tous 80000 yvelinois selon
les organisateurs des élus des parents
mais aussi des jeunes par mieux etienne
berthier à 21 ans il assume sa position
de conservateurs oui on pourrait se dire
les jeunes sont pour le progrès en soi
mais pas n'importe quels progrès
vraiment réfléchir à construire un
progrès et voilà c'est pour ça je pense
que cette fois en tout cas cette fois
nécessite plus de concertation ça allait
très vite on a vu que ça est un sujet
clivant pour la france pourquoi ne pas
prendre plus de temps parce que même de
bière à la 10 et un changement de
civilisation
clémence maral en est à sa dixième
manifestation peut être 15 elle ne les
compte plus pour elle c'est l'idéologie
de mai 68 qui est en cause alors pour
que les enfants aient droit à un père et
une mère
elle est prête à jouer les contre
révolutionnaires on entre jeunes on se
dit dans les pattes se nomme dans nos
dans ma conviction c'est ça fait ça fait
vraiment très plaisir de voir qu'on est
toutes les générations qui se lève et
c'est clairement haussé le moteur à
chaque fois on est passé dans une
fiction et pas que les vieux qui sont
ces dépenses et là on est on est on est
bien ceux qui se lèvent et c'est juste
trop beau et c'est alors même si la loi
a été promulguée les jeunes activistes
espère encore que le président la retire
comme cela avait été le cas en 2006 et
1984 pour les lois du cpe et de l'école
libre que doit devenir maintenant ce
mouvement de la manif pour tous l'une de
ses porte parole la plus emblématique
frigide barjot estime qu'elle a fait son
temps et qu'elle n'était pas appelé à
devenir un parti politique
qu'en pensez-vous les manifestations
doivent-elles se poursuivre la
contestation doit-elle prendre une autre
forme
micro trottoir maintenant que la loi est
passée je pense que c'est un petit peu
tombée en désuétude bon après on peut
rester sur ses idées malgré tout mais
les moyens d'agir sans limite et
maintenant ça va s'arrêter
mais je pense qu'il va cesser
par fatigue des manifestants
probablement fuit parce que cela fait la
troisième je crois qui se déroulait donc
je pense pas que les manies soit faite
pour être reconduit tous les mois navis
aboutir à rien je pense que voilà ils
ont dit ce qu'ils avaient à dire
la loi est passée je sais pas je sais
que ça c'est assez gros de voir autant
de personnes et je pense que ça va
toucher touché pas mal de gens après je
sais pas si le mouvement va continuer
avec la présidente a changé il me semble
aussi donc je sais pas du tout comment
ça va continuer pour le député ump de la
3e circonscription des yvelines en tout
cas la mobilisation ne doit pas
s'arrêter henri guaino ump donc se dit
prêt à protester indéfiniment dans une
société libre on a le droit de
manifester at il ajouté sur l'antenne de
canal+ ce week end toujours concernant
henri guaino sachez aussi qu'il reste
convoqué mercredi 29 mai par la brigade
de la répression de la délinquance sur
la personne mais qui ne se rendra pas à
cette convocation
le député poursuivi à l'initiative de
l'union syndicale des magistrats pour
avoir porté des déclarations à
l'encontre du juge jean michel gentil au
lendemain de la mise en examen de
nicolas sarkozy dans l' affaire
bettencourt un dernier mot de politique
aussi pour vous donner les dates de
l'élection cantonale partielle de
mantes-la-jolie suite à la démission du
conseiller général michel vialay ce sera
dimanche le 30 juin de 8 heures à 20
heures dans les bureaux de vote de la
commune de mantes-la-jolie un second
tour pourrait se tenir si besoin le
dimanche 7 juillet les dépôts des
candidatures vont débuter le 3 juin
seront opposés pour l'instant
vraisemblablement pierre bédier ancien
président du conseil général des
yvelines qui vient de purger une peine
d'inégibilité et rama sall la candidate
socialiste secrétaire général des jeunes
socialistes la campagne sur le terrain a
déjà commencé pierre bédier vient de
recevoir le soutien de l'actuel
président du conseil général des
yvelines alain schmitz et qui estime que
ce retour est une réelle opportunité